à auxerre guillaume larrivé nous attend
battu par aig différence ce soir bonsoir
guillaume larrivé on évoqué
l'implantation du maire socialiste est
ce que c'est ça qui fait la différence
selon vous ce soir
moi je veux d'abord dire un très grand
merci à ces milliers de ces rois et de
ses rois qui me font confiance j'ai
gagné
1200 voix par rapport à 2012 par rapport
à l'élection du député la dynamique à a
clairement été de mon côté à la tête
d'une belle équipe il me manque en
réalité 160 voix pour faire la
différence par rapport au candidat
socialiste ce soir c'est vrai je suis
triste pour auxerre car je considère que
cette victoire de monsieur perez est une
défaite pour auxerre mais je reste comme
député pleinement au service des
auxerroises et des auxerrois bien sûr la
session d'hier ex aequo est ce que
finalement c'est justement pas ce mandat
de député qui vous empêche d'accéder à
la mairie d'auxerre les gens sont
diaries va être plus à l'assemblée
nationale que chez nous est ce que vous
pensez pas que c'est ça finalement qui
ne paradoxalement a été un handicap pour
votre candidature non écoutés quand on
regarde très précisément les choses on
voit en réalité que l'élection s'est
jouée dans dans deux quartiers de
quartiers dans lesquels le maire
socialiste à mener je le dis très
directement ces derniers jours une
campagne haineuse à mon égard une
campagne ordurière qui je le crains a
malheureusement fait la différence